[Music]
okay so the the sheriff of floor of this
florida uh uh community
uh wants to let you know that he found
your 770 pounds of pot and he would like
to return it to you whomever you are oh
[ __ ]
oh thanks sheriff dude what a cool
sheriff what's the [ __ ] catch dude i
totally pick it up
what's the catch she's trying to catch
you literally he's like oh yeah if you
uh let me know if you want it gotcha
no catch no he just says hey look we
found it
you just let us know it's all pot
worth about two million dollars by the
way
where the [ __ ] they find it yeah how do
you find so much
someone's gonna die county is that is
that dwayne it's called brevard county
and where i mean uh what stage oh yeah
it's florida
and uh they basically say
they're trying to return lost items they
posted this oh nice dude the lost and
found posted the picture of the
narcotics
and they say if you happen to have lost
or misplaced approximately 770 pounds of
high grade marijuana 107. hi great and
would like to have your property return
please contact our narcotics agents and
we're more than happy to reunite you
with your lost property all of us at one
point or another in our lives have lost
or misplaced something important and
we're very hopeful that a good kind
person who lost an item
will come forward and collect your stuff
um so yeah all you have to do is come
down to our criminal investigation
services building on gus hit boulevard
in rockledge and claim your property
with no strings attached once we
properly identify as the rightful owner
we'll gladly return your property and
make sure both you and your property are
kept in a secure area so no one can try
to rip you off hey you know what though
if i go pick it up it's my stuff and
they said that on the ad they can't
arrest me right now they're gonna put
you in a secure area they said you dumb
ass dude cop
can't lie dude they can't lie the
secured area is the highlight turn if i
ask you if you're a cop because it's
probably your job it's the same rule if
they touch your dick then they're
definitely not a cop not a cop not a cop
they're just uh just a hook-up yep
no strings you can't do it if an
undercover cop can't touch your dick
yeah i want to put you in a secure area
no strings attached that's [ __ ] funny
dude you know what that means they're
going to take me to [ __ ] a round
table pizza yeah dude secure area i love
that place the evidence room come to the
criminal investigation let our narcotics
agents know
it's like what the [ __ ] dude anything is
not that dude they said they're gonna
give it to me they're purposely not
telling you where they found it because
that's part of how they get you yeah
would be tight if this was like a tea
bag they're trying to teabag
like the biggest drug dealers in the
area where like maybe there's like two a
drug deal gone wrong between two rival
gangs
and then they were able to intercept it
and then both gang leaders are like what
happened to all the marijuana what's all
the marijuana and they're like oops i
don't know how we found all this but we
have it now and then they're kind of
like punking everyone in the
neighborhood i'd be tired if they did do
that yeah
and then the following they're like hey
we found this murdered body whoever uh
did the crime if you want like to hide
this evidence we found it just feel free
to hit us up
homicide division yeah i'll stop by i'm
gullible the look on the guy's face
the look on the guy's face was gullible
enough to read something like this and
then show up and then once he gets there
they're like come on oh what
hey hey i thought you said you said no
strings attached what's going on what
the [ __ ] i could love that guy what
about bart's situation though where it's
like the drug lords are like looking at
the middle man who lost it like one guy
like [ __ ] did the wrong deal right so
the juggler's like i don't give a [ __ ]
where it is you better go get it so this
guy's like oh i gotta go claim it you
know what i'm saying
i do know you're saying what a [ __ ]
you're another idiot and you see this ad
and you're like free weed bruh i'm just
gonna go claiming myself
and you guard us likely i'm pretty sure
but that's like what happens like
there's all kinds of i mean potato the
potato story there's all kinds of people
coming forward say i [ __ ] killed her
i did it yeah but then there's whack
goes on because they wanted the the fame
yeah they want like a little bit of the
action of their board as [ __ ] or who
knows such a weird way to want fame like
weird it's like do i want to risk life
imprisonment just in case [ __ ] it i want
the fame it's super weird but yeah
there's people who will do that to be
part of a story to feel like they're
real or whatever the [ __ ] is going on in
their lives the cops would really be a
troll like would really be trolls if
that wasn't actually like high grade
weed you know it's like like skunks [ __ ]
like it was just snickle fritz yeah
snicker [ __ ] snicker fish it's really
bad weed dude
is that the modern day word for stress
i guess i don't know this is a danish
word for pastry
yeah
but yeah that's cool how how much what's
what's the worth of all those one
million oh two seven million two million
dude not man that's only so many i feel
like some drug mule is going to get
killed
for losing this [ __ ] that's exactly
or they're being forced to be like i do
have to go claim it or maybe that's the
security area i want to go to i'm either
going to get killed for losing this or
going to a secured area or you know
there jason bateman's like he's like
sweating his ass off right now too he's
like oh my [ __ ] guy i gotta explain
this there's gonna be another season of
old school there is coming out like next
friday oh is it next friday eating me oh
is it season three or four oh
season four bro yes do you watch the
ozarks i don't oh you gotta watch you
gotta catch yourself so good
do you like breaking bad
no okay i've only finished have you
watched breaking bad then we're [ __ ]
guys
i haven't seen it you like do you like
crime drama okay i like um i like
snowfall okay oh you'll like this okay
cool okay but start with breaking bad
watch all seven seasons because you have
to watch that first get in the movies
then the movie el camino then watch el
camino then you can watch ozarks okay
noted why it's a primer it's about a an
accountant
that works for the cartel and it's
really good the name doesn't sound like
it sounds like some harry potter [ __ ]
and it's very close there's wizards that
get involved later wait it's a hybrid
like harry potter no i love harry potter
oh i was just saying i [ __ ] hate
harry potter
that was gonna be a sick moment no
you're not like harry potter i just
never got into it i think it's too old
you don't have to dislike it i was too
old too i think i was
you don't believe in magic i do
i think i love magic dude when i see
people wearing the robes and [ __ ] like i
really [ __ ] lose my [ __ ] a little bit
you know what i don't like about the
hair i like harry potter but i what i
don't like about it is when people like
ask each other like other harry potter
fans they go what's your house dude
that is i hate that too dude it's like
shut up yeah shut up no i don't mind it
when they ask like what's your house i
hate it when they like you're so this
house yeah yeah yeah you know any of
that stuff you said so slytherin such a
hufflepuff
shut up dude i'll punch your face if you
ask me what house that sounds whack dude
it's whack as [ __ ] bro i do like the
movies though but back to ozark though
uh c's in in order uh because i haven't
seen season three one two and three
which one's like the best you haven't
seen season three i've not seen either
three bro i haven't finished season
three either
good they're all good you gotta watch
just watch them in order dude season
three and watch season three
season three season three
it's different but like the ramp up of
season three is crazy right okay so i
think what you're telling me is wait
till season four finishes and then binge
watch both well
see yeah see not wrong with it season
one was absolutely my [ __ ] lit season
one was sick
season two
that's why i didn't go into season three
because i was like it's good but two my
favorite i kind of had a crush on the
ground season two that was the first
crush i ever uh first grandmother uh the
latest question i've ever had i got
married for no reason you mean the
psychopath grandma yeah that's why i
like that she [ __ ] hard you know she's
a hard [ __ ] she [ __ ] really she don't
play when she she'll kill your ass which
is kind of cool russ langmore favorite
storyline i enjoyed langmore okay
best storyline which one's lane moore
you know who elaine moore is dude
the the white church people the brothers
the white trash people you've well no
spoilers i already know ruth ruth ruth's
brothers oh
uncle yeah ruth is like the best actress
on the whole show she's so [ __ ] dude
the best actor on the show have you seen
her in that one movie the assistant
what's the assistant i think it's like
uh kind of like on the harvey weinstein
type of thing great title she um she's
she's an assistant that goes into like
hollywood producer situation and the
whole set is like her just like
literally her first day on the job and
then there's just signs of like that
type of adultery that kind of happens
and then the way that like people within
that industry kind of treat other people
and she has this just has to go in there
and she like finds like an earring on
the floor she finds like weird stuff and
it's kind of like
yeah just transcending around and it's
the uh
it's just one of those perspectives
where you just follow her on her first
day but then you get the shadow of like
straight up harvey weinstein like in the
entire ecosystem it's really crazy oh
but she crushes it too yeah she's a
really good really good at playing
that interesting side role that like
kind of like she's constantly in an
uncomfortable position too you know what
i'm saying really good she thrives yeah
she's good at that she's good at picking
up something and then being like
about it
she's the best i've ever seen i know
do you guys watch snowfall which one i
don't even know what that is i heard
it's really good which one it's on fx so
behind is that like a cocaine thing yeah
yeah it's cool it's amazing what what's
uh what um channel is it on platform fx
yeah you're watching on hulu i think
okay hulu how'd you use breaking bad
what happened what was what was going on
in your life
i don't know i only i only got into
snowfall because of rick
he loves that [ __ ] yeah holly if you
don't mind she's much much much younger
than my early 20s
i see what about
rick never watch breaking bad no
i don't wait no yes he has yeah does he
like it nobody likes it i don't know i
bet he likes it rick has good tasting
content yeah he loves drug [ __ ]
yeah
yeah breaking bad is like the premier
drug [ __ ] started it i think i think for
this era anyway yeah yeah but you got to
watch ozark is good you start watching
breaking bad now and season one is still
really good yeah it still holds up
incredible you could re-watch it a
couple times yeah so we started watching
raising canaan too
well we finished racing do you eat
raisin canes while you watch raisin king
we call it that though but now we're
we're starting power because of the
story
but yeah starting power now i know it's
backwards but
did you guys have pokemon cards yes okay
i also i also grew up in vietnam so it
was a lot of fun did you watch duke
it's a maori show
we gotta watch all five seasons
right now we're gonna watch people have
them right now i'll hold them down
[Music]